well fought more on the government's
response to this crisis and indeed what
was on that rather large cargo plane
care Minister Helen lately at joins us
now
minister really good to see you again
and let's start shall we with that a
transport plane that came in from Turkey
in the wee hours of the morning said to
be canning at PPE kit can you give us
any details as to exactly what was
onboard so you're correct that the plane
has now arrived bringing really vital PP
with it the consignment is being checked
at the moment because what we do know
with some of these deliveries is they
don't always have exactly what you
expecting to have on it and it's
absolutely vital to make sure that the
kids is what we need and up to
specification because as you'll know we
want to make sure that not only do we
get PPE to our frontline health and
social care workers but also that it is
the right equipment and meet safety
specky that specification so it's being
checked to make sure that it's what we
need sure well fingers crossed we can we
can perhaps get a little bit more detail
from yourself another government
represented once those those checks have
been carried out are we expecting
further deliveries from this Turkish
supplier if so when then we're getting
ongoing deliveries from overseas as
humans work and one particularly to get
deliveries of materials from China
because have some things that can only
be produced in China with raw materials
they have but overall we have a PPE
strategy which is both bringing imports
of PPE to the UK and increase in what
we're producing here in the UK because
there is a global shortage of PPE and we
absolutely know that we need to have the
equipment for our frontline workers just
in terms of this this supply chain route
from from Turkey's as we were hearing
from our correspondent and a brady done
it at Brys not and there were clearly
some issues around getting the material
or getting the equipment and then
getting it to a plane and then getting
it here do you anticipate any subsequent
problems of that nature with this
particular supply route I can't tell you
about the specific supply routes from
Turkey also do know is that we are
working with suppliers when the world to
get the equipment that we need it is
know the reality when you're import
this equipment from around the world is
it come sometimes there are issues were
what you expected to get isn't exactly
what you actually get and that is one of
the challenges and that's one reason why
we're making sure we are getting in as
much equipment as we can that meets the
UK specification so that we've got the
supplies that we need thank you and I
wonder if we might focus for a second on
the deu equipment procurement asking
which of which we are we are now a part
and the change in the position from the
foreign secretaries permanent secretary
Simon McDonald and yesterday he appeared
to suggest when in fact he did suggest
he stated that explicitly that a
political decision had been made not to
be part of the scheme he later rolled
back on that just explained exactly why
we were in this position why the
permanent secretary to the foreign
office didn't wasn't in a full command
of the facts and what the situation is
currently with us EU scheme I mean there
do seem to have been some
misunderstandings about the EU scheme
I'm sure that absolutely was no
political decision made about the
involvement in it the reason we weren't
involved in the initial scheme was to do
with the communications error we're now
already participating in one scheme and
we're ready to participate in future
schemes I mean I think one thing that's
worthwhile Caesaria the EU's PPE
procurement schemes and so I hope that
you that they do bring PP into the EU so
far they have yet to actually deliver
anything and the important thing is that
we have supplies coming in as fast as we
can possibly get them indeed but in
terms of this failure of communications
the suggestion appears to be that emails
were sent to out of out of use in boxes
somewhere in Whitehall I mean if that's
the case it does rather suggest that
someone at this end of the conversation
made a mistake and not updating their
details with the European Union this
this feels like speculation about what
may or may not have happened and I do
know that there has been no
communications error can you tell us any
more than about me exactly what the
communications error was then I don't
have any further information
tell you about that we know that that
has happened and that we will
participate we're participating when one
scheme we will participate in future
scheme so they sent the extent that it
makes good sense to do so what is the
important thing is to be making sure
that we are getting the pipi that we
need as we've just been talking about
we've had the delivery from Turkey
yesterday we're expecting more delivery
this morning expecting more deliveries
during the course of this week let's
focus on getting the P P P V that we
need into the country for our workforce
I see your wedding your your care badge
showing your support for those working
in the K and the social care sectors and
yesterday of course we had some fairly
dramatic figures revealing the extent of
the losses at the extent of the deaths
that have been taking place in our care
homes fivefold increase in deaths we
were you surprised by the scale of those
losses I mean it is really really hard
the situation in care homes and also for
those providing home care because there
you have some of the people in the
country who are the most vulnerable
who are often older and with underlying
health conditions so they do catch
coronavirus there are real risk of of
complications and and and at risk of
dying so we know though it's been
difficult to be able to get the sort of
accurate data and data that is specific
to the care sector as opposed to
including Hospital data but we do know
that there's people have been dying in
in care homes as the ONS data said
yesterday and I am working to make sure
that next week we'll be able to share
more up-to-date data but you know it is
I know it's really really really hard
for the families for people who have
lost their lives for those between care
and also the care homes themselves you
are coping and looking after residents
often that those that staff have known
for four months and not years I mean
it's really really hard it's really hard
um but just in terms of of those deaths
it was it was only in the third week of
this crisis that the government
identifying that there was something
pretty major something pretty bad going
on in our care sector care home
providers are telling Sky News that
there was a strategy of clearing beds in
hospitals and putting them into care
homes for the best part of three weeks
none of those were being texted we in
essence put the fox in the hen house we
allowed people who potentially had
covered 19 to associate with some of the
most vulnerable in our society I mean it
perhaps shouldn't be a surprise that we
saw fivefold increase in deaths and care
homes today so part of our strategy has
been to make sure that the NHS can cope
and then the NHS was able to look after
people who'd be admitted to hospital and
particularly to intensive care because
that is where we can save lives and that
involved people who were fit to be
discharged from hospital being
discharged with very clear guidance on
for instance making sure that there was
isolation and infection control all the
time we're learning about coronavirus
and how difficult in fact it is to
manage as an infection and we have
updated the guidance to make sure that
firstly well as testing increases we're
now able to test every single patient
who's being discharged from hospital if
they're due to go to a care home and we
also want to see every single patient
discharge going through a period of
isolation or quarantine if they haven't
gone through that within their time in
hospital can you give us a bigger gun
yeah so can you give us a figure then
for the extent of testing within the
care home sector how many care home
staff have received a test so it's so
far over 10,000 care home residents have
received a test they were 13,000 himself
has been about over 18,000 care home
staff have been referred for testing
that figure how many people are actually
having tests because we ask public
health England we ask the Care Quality
Commission you know we ask your
department and it doesn't appear that
there's a figure yet
so we're bringing together the figures
on that number of staff you've actually
had a test on it and it's partly because
there are multiple testing sites going
on and also some of them are being
tested at the sites we've now starting
satellite testing so mobile testings
going on and there's also some testing
by public health England so that
multiple places where the testing is
taking place and bringing together that
information so that we can track not
only the number of being referred for
tests which I said but also the number
who actually are being tested because
that's really important yeah I think the
problem for a lot of care home employees
that we've been speaking to is that
often they're having to drive 60 70 80 a
hundred miles to get to one of these
centers when actually what they need to
be doing is staying in that clear woman
and providing care so when are we going
to be able to get to the stage which
both yourself and the health secretary
have talked about when we are delivering
tests to them when death when tests are
being popped through their letterbox or
indeed a mobile testing violence running
up at the care home itself when is that
I mean of course those are being tested
are usually those will be those who have
symptoms so they won't be at work but
you're absolutely right that I know that
it is difficult and has been difficult
ready for care workers to get to the
testing sites because they're not
necessary nearby and not everybody has a
car at the moment we have 27 testing
driver testing sites and that is going
to increase up to 50 but hand in hand
with that and we have started we started
piloting and so some mobile testing for
that goes closer to where people are and
we're going to be sending up home
testing kits that will be delivered to
people so that will make it even easier
to be able to get the tests that you
need so these are the steps we are
taking to make sure that we can actually
use the testing capacity that we've got
in the country to test as many people as
possible and they will be gratefully
received when they arrive I'm sure but
just in terms of what we are learning
this morning the front page of The
Telegraph suggests that thousands of the
tests that have been carried out are now
considered to be invalid what is going
on there and what will happen to those
people who received
an invalid test so my understanding from
the clinical advisors is that some of
the early tests were evaluated and the
evaluation was actually they weren't
effective enough and that this is a kind
of a normal process when you are using a
test for an illness when when as we know
this is a nooner illness and we're
learning all the time
those who were tested with the test that
we you think isn't up to scratch have
been written to to let them know when
they will be offered another test is
that the potential then that we have
sent people to work on the NHS front
line to work in care homes with
coronavirus well in general we know that
the guidance has been to people if you
have symptoms to make sure that you are
isolating we have to make sure that we
look at the reliability of tests and
this has been also the whole debate
around the testing of people who don't
have symptoms for instance and one
reason why the testing is focused on
people have you do have symptoms because
we know that the testing is most
accurate when you have symptoms so this
is really really important not just to
test but to make sure we are testing
people effectively for the reason that
you say that you need to make sure that
it's given you accurate results on which
decisions can then be made Helen Whitley
always good to see you do continue to
stay well and thanks for being with us
thank you very much